you brought your children with you right
for two of the trips you did okay how
was that I know because probably
different because that's what the farms
all ballots were embracing yeah my
children but how was that to you still
have a role as a mom but then you're
also in FileMaker producer director mode
it's really a juggling act I mean Sarah
brought her son on all of the trips
basic yeah because he was really little
and we would have someone come with us
who could help like a doula or somebody
who wanted to come to the farm and meet
anime so they had this incentive there
and then they would look after OB and it
was really really hard I mean usually we
shot all in natural light so at the end
of the day we were done it wasn't like
we would go off in the night except that
one trip when they were there of our so
it's hard the short answer is that it
was brutal it was hard it was really
hard and but but it was also great
unfortunately the trip that they came we
timed it wrong and they came like in the
middle of the winter and it was freezing
and they couldn't really play outside
and when we went in the summer we felt
like only they could have caused like
why does we have the one summer because
it's just heaven it's like a playground
you know so it's hard you know it's just
constantly trying to balance things and
rush back and breastfeed the baby and
then like rush back to shoot more but
you know this culture completely
supported us and and they all understand
they they're all mothers they've been
through it when they were beginning you
know becoming midwives they had to rush
off and come back and they they I think
they recognize that in us they wouldn't
Pamela's
it went well she just she was like oh
you two are just like midwives good way
because they you know they shared they
lived in households together and so if
one of them had to brush off the others
would take care of the kids or you know
or bring the nursing baby over to the
long who is at work and then come you
know and then bring the baby back with
what the mom still stays off delivering
a baby and we had that kind of flow
where like we would be shooting in ina
may's house and my baby would need you
know to be fed and i would like you know
run and meet the doula and feed the baby
and then run back to to set and and keep
and keep working um so it was like a
very high compliment that she said you
know you sort of have each other's backs
and are like collaborating in that sort
of way and and not having to talk a lot
about it either i know she sort of was
impressed that like Mary put her hand up
and I like foot cord in her hands you
know before she even asked for it yeah
oh so that was really sweet I I think a
lot about just like if if we want a
women women's voices in film how do we
support women who are also mothers in
making them and I I don't know what the
answer is to that but I think it's an
important question for people to ask um
and and at least part of the solution
that we found in this was working
together and that like sharing the
workload and also sharing you know
sharing the the motherhood identity is
super helpful because you know if you're
if I remember there was one time where
the babysitter who is taking care of
Mary's kids her head broke her arm and
so like this kid over here breaks her
arm that means the babysitter can't come
to work which means this mom can't go to
work which means you know this vaughn
can't go to work you know it's like this
this thing because because at the end of
the day like we have to we
so we all have to do our part and taking
care of our families and our kids men
too of course but that's why we listed
our babysitters in our credits because
we wanted to acknowledge the important
part that they played in in the
filmmaking yeah okay oh no I mean it was
it was kind of a circus and then we
didn't bring them on the next year and
then we would do more of a streamline
you know like five day go in and shoot
12 hours a day for five days and then go
out and go back home and we found that
that worked better except one other trip
where we were waiting on a birth and so
we didn't know how long we'd be gone so
we brought you brought one I brought my
son and we waited for eight days we just
SAT house I mean we should this shot
them but we we also just waited you know
and so it was nice to have our kids then
it was different you know because we
were mostly idle right well I think
you'd mentioned in a prior interview on
makers that you know we can talk
nowadays that we can't have it all and
and it really it's a hard balance and
that you were saying that women really
need to share their secrets aren't even
secrets but just communicate on how they
are able to balance being along working
in creative logistics yeah it's like if
you can talk about it just that's like
that it's such a gift for one woman to
say like well this is actually how we
did it you know we had this babysitter
who would come on the shoots with us for
this period of time and we found her
through this thing and that you know and
and then also to misery like you know it
was that it was that it was very
challenging I know and the filmmakers
that we have met the women filmmakers
that we've met I feel like you know
we're like oh you know it's a great
thing you know we've made a film and
that's wonderful but how do you do it
you know we're all asked we're asking
these women all the time
how does it work for you um because it's
very hard if there's also it's a great
thing because you're on you know and you
need to go and shoot and it's a lot of
hours but then your home you know so
it's not like this consistent thing
you're not shooting all the time you
know so there is a balance there but
when you're shooting it's very very
challenging well then the Edit was hard
and the Edit was hard because that was
regular business hours you know I mean
we were yeah they're from and whether
they're all that all day long and we
edited for ten months so it was a long
long edit um yeah it's hardly knows they
would be sick like my son was sick home
from school and I'd bring him to the
Edit room and like he loved it he loved
it he still talks about it but it's like
you know I'm trying to like have a
conversation and you know my heart's
there but I have to finish this and you
know it's just a very hard balance we
brought my six-year-old to San Francisco
for a screening of the phone and it she
was very excited to be at the movie
theater because she got Luke free
popcorn from the popcorn lady that was
like the highlight to her but but she
said to me Mommy you know what I want to
be when I grew up she said I want to be
a mommy and I want to make movies about
babies so it was like you know the
challenging part is feeling like oh I'm
not with my kids and then the beautiful
part is that you're inspiring him in
whatever way toward their own creativity
and Sarah would remind me of that around
day five after we've been gone for five
days I would start feeling like my heart
hurt and she'd remind me of that and I
believe that so much to I think it's
important to be a role model for your
for your children and and follow what
you love to do and you know it's really
important
you